WITH KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE,
JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS,
DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
OKAY.
SOME MEDIA OUTLETS ARE GETTING
HEAT FOR COMMENTS REGARDING
NORTH KOREA AND KIM’S LITTLE
SISTER.
"NEW YORK TIMES" HEADLINE READS
"KIM JONG UN’S SISTER TURNS ON
THE CHARM, TAKING THE
SPOTLIGHT."
CNN SAYS THE DIPLOMATIC DANCE.
KIM JONG UN’S YOUNGER SISTER
WOULD BE FAVORED TO END GOLD.
OUT KNOW WHAT IS WORSE, THE LAME
JOKE LIMPING TOWARDS YOU.
YAHOO! NEWS WROTE ALL SWAGGER
AND SMILES, KIM JONG UN’S
HISTORY SISTER GETS HER STAR
TURN.
WHAT IS THIS, THE RED CARPET?
I CAN’T BELIEVE THEY LEFT OUT
WHO SHE WAS WEARING.
LITERALLY.
I FEEL PRETTY LEFT OUT IN THIS
LOVEFEST.
IN HONOR OF VALENTINE’S DAY, I
MADE THIS.
♫ ♫
>> Kimberly: TWO OF YOU.
EVEN MORE DISTURBING.
>> Greg: NBC TWEETED IT WAS SO
SATISFYING TO WATCH.
NEGLECTED TO POINT OUT THE
OPTION OF NOT SHARING HIS
EXECUTION.
THEN THERE IS "THE VIEW."
>> WAS THAT THE PLACE TO MAKE
THAT STATEMENT?
>> I THOUGHT MIKE PENCE SAID IT
WAS INAPPROPRIATE TO MAKE
POLITICAL STATEMENTS AT SPORTING
EVENTS.
[APPLAUSE]
WASN’T HE THE GUY WHO WALKED OUT
OF THE FOOTBALL GAME BECAUSE
PEOPLE WERE KNEELING AN
OUTSTANDING?
>> IF YOU WERE IN KOREA, YOU
NEED TO STAND UP.
STAND UP AND SHOW RESPECT.
>> Greg: PENCE DIDN’T STAND
UP.
YOU KNOW YOU ARE A LEFTY IF YOU
THINK IT IS HEROIC TO NEIL FOR
OUR NATIONAL ANTHEM BY EVIL IF
YOU SET FOR OUR ADVERSARIES.
IT’S FUNNY THEY ARE CALLED "THE
VIEW," YET THEY ARE SO BLIND.
WHY DOES THE MEDIA.
AS A COUNTRY SO BAD TO ITS
PEOPLE?
IT IS WHAT THEY DO.
USSR WAS PORTRAYED LOVINGLY FOR
DECADES.
SAME THING WITH CASTRO’S CUBA
AND VENEZUELA.
AFTER ALL THE REVIEWS FROM THE
MEDIA, HOW NERVOUS IS KIM’S
SISTER RIGHT NOW?
DOES SHE REALLY WANT TO BE MORE
POPULAR THAN HIM?
GET A LOOK AT HER NOW.
IT MIGHT BE THE LAST TIME YOU
SEE HER.
>> Dana: [LAUGHS]
I DIDN’T MEAN TO LAUGH.
>> Greg: HOW DARE YOU LAUGH AT
THAT.
YOU ARE A HORRIBLE PERSON.
>> Dana: I DIDN’T MEAN TO.
>> Greg: WHO SHOULD BE MORE
WORRIED?
SHOULD SHE BE MORE WORRIED BEING
SEEN AS A RISING STAR OR SHOULD
HE BE MORE WORRIED BECAUSE HE
MIGHT BE REPLACED.
>> Dana: THEN SHE SHOULD BE
MORE WORRIED.
IN THAT SCENARIO.
I DO THINK NORTH KOREA, AS SOON
AS I KNEW THEY WERE GOING TO
OFFER TO DO TALKS WITH THE
SOUTH KOREANS AND GET TO THE
OLYMPICS, I COULD KIND OF SEE
THIS COMING.
THERE IS TALK FOR A TALK’S SAKE.
THIS IS A CENTURY-OLD GAME WHERE
SOFT POWER, CHARM OFFENSIVE IS
USED.
IT’S A GAME WE DON’T HAVE TO
PLAY ALONG WITH.
I THINK PENCE DID THE RIGHT
THING.
THINKING ABOUT WHAT THE COVERAGE
WOULD’VE BEEN LIKE IF IT HAD
BEEN BIDEN WHO HAD BEEN SENT
THERE.
THAT SAID HE DID THE EXACT SAME
THING AS PENCE.
HOW WOULD THE MEDIA HAVE TALKED
ABOUT IT?
>> Greg: HEROIC AND STRONG.
STANDING UP TO THESE PEOPLE.
AND YET MIKE’S SITTING.
-- MIKE.
I CALLED HIM MIKE.
WE ARE IN THE SAME SQUASH CLUB.
IT IS LIKE THEY CAN’T SEE HOW
THEY BELIEVE SITTING FOR THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM IS HEROIC BUT
THIS IS BAD.
>> Jesse: THEY FELL FOR THE
OLDEST TRICK IN THE BOOK.
YOU GET A YOUNG.
NEW WOMAN TO SELL YOUR PRODUCT.
THAT’S WHAT HE IS DOING.
SELLS HIS YOUNGER SISTER OVER
AND THAT IS SUPPOSED TO TAKE THE
EDGE OFF THE REGIME.
MEANWHILE THE REGIME IS KILLING
PEOPLE IN CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
THE NORTH KOREANS WANT TO DRIVE
A WEDGE BETWEEN THE
SOUTH KOREANS AND THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY PULLED THE U.S. MEDIA INTO
IT.
FOR THE NORTH KOREANS.
THEY THINK THEY ARE WORLDLY AND
SOPHISTICATED AND INFORMED BUT
THEY WERE DUPED BY A DICTATOR.
DO YOUR POINT, THEY THINK THEY
MEDIA DIPLOMACY TRUMPS
EVERYTHING.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT THE
RESULTS.
THEY SEE A HANDSHAKE OR SMILE OR
TREATY OR SUMMIT AND THAT’S THE
END GOAL.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT THE
RESULTS.
THE OTHER THING THAT WAS
INTERESTING WAS THAT THE MEDIA,
SELF TRAPPING AND PROPAGANDA.
THE U.S. MEDIA SEEMS SO INTENT
ON NOT BEING PRO-AMERICAN THAT
THEY WENT SO OUT OF THEIR WAY
AND THEY COZIED UP TO A HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSER.
THIS WAS FROM REUTERS.
"THE CROWD APPLAUDED AS SHE
STOOD FOR THE SOUTH KOREAN
ANTHEM.
HER SMILE AND MANNER LEFT A
LARGELY POSITIVE IMPRESSION ON
THE SOUTH."
THEY TRICKED THE READER INTO
THINKING THE CROWD APPLAUDED FOR
LITTLE ROCKET MAN’S SISTER WHEN
THEY WERE APPLAUDING FOR THEIR
OWN NATIONAL ANTHEM.
ALSO TRICKING THE READER INTO
THINKING THAT THE SOUTH KOREANS
ARE WARMING UP TO LITTLE ROCKET
MAN’S SISTER.
WILLIE GEIST, WHO I RESPECT SAID
"I CAN REPORT SOUTH KOREANS HERE
OR ARE NOT AS ENTHRALLED WITH
KIM YO JONG AS THE NORTH KOREAN
CHEERLEADERS AS IT SEEMS SOME IN
THE MEDIA ARE BACK HOME.
SOMETHING ABOUT THE NORTH
KILLING, STARVING AND
IMPRISONING ITS OWN PEOPLE."
THAT SAYS IT ALL.
>> Greg: JAKE TABBERT DID CALL
OUT CNN ON IT.
MEGHAN McCAIN ON "THE VIEW"
THAT I WOULDN’T HAVE SAT EITHER.
DO WE HAVE "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
TWEET?
THERE WE ARE.
WITHOUT A WORD, ONLY FLASHING
SMILES, KIM JONG UN’S SISTER
OUTFLANKED VICE PRESIDENT
MIKE PENCE IN DIPLOMACY."
IF IT WASN’T PENCE, THEY
COULDN’T WRITE THAT BUT PENCE
GAVE THEM THE ABILITY TO WRITE
THAT.
>> Kimberly: WHO APPROVED THAT
HEADLINE?
IT IS SO RIDICULOUS.
THEY ARE CONDONING AND
CELEBRATING A MURDEROUS REGIME,
IT IS POOR BOY OTTO WARMBIER.
RETURNED HIM BACK TO US, THE
POOR THING.
IT’S IS SO HORRENDOUS THEY WOULD
DO THIS.
THEY ARE ACTING LIKE SHE IS A
KARDASHIAN OR SOMETHING.
WHAT IS SHE WEARING, WHAT ABOUT
THIS, HOW FABULOUS.
IT’S UNBELIEVABLE HOW FAR THEY
WILL GO.
ANOTHER HEADLINE CALLING HER THE
IVANKA TRUMP OF NORTH KOREA.
YOU CAN’T EVEN MAKE THIS STUFF
OUT, IT IS SO LOONEY TUNES.
YET THEY SEEM TO GET AWAY WITH
IT.
>> Greg: MORE LIKE TIFFANY
TRUMP.
I DON’T KNOW.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
JUAN, YOU ARE OUR HISTORIAN.
YOU’VE BEEN WRITING FOR YEARS.
WHEN I MAKE A POINT ABOUT THIS
NOT BEING NEW, THE IDEA THAT
REPORTERS KIND OF INDULGING
ADVERSARIES OR OPPRESSORS.
WE SAW IT THE USSR.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," WITH
CASTRO, HUGO CHAVEZ.
WHAT IS THE INCLINATION, WHY
DOES -- WHY IS THIS A BLIND
SPOT?
>> Juan: THEY ROMANTICIZE
REBELS.
I THINK WE DO THAT IN ALL MEDIA.
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDERDOGS AND
REBELS.
THE ASSUMPTION IS THE
UNITED STATES, THAT WE HAVE ALL
THE POWER IN OUR HANDS.
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT COMPANIES.
WE HAVE THE MOST POWERFUL
MILITARY AND LARGEST ECONOMY.
THERE’S THIS SENSE OF WE SHOULD
GIVE A FAIR SHOT TO THIS LITTLE
GUY EVEN IF THE LITTLE GUY IS A
REPRESSIVE TORTURE OF
HUMAN BEINGS.
IN THIS CASE, THAT’S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
WHERE I DISAGREE WITH YOU AS I
THINK JESSE IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
THIS IS NEWS.
STOP, AMERICA.
THEY SENT OUT A PRETTY YOUNG
WOMAN.
SHE STANDS UP, LIKE THE
IVANKA TRUMP.
THAT’S WHAT THEY SAID.
THEY SEE HER AS OLD, MY GOSH.
THIS IS THE NORTH KOREAN
PRINCESS.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE
DETERMINED, NOT HAPPY DAD IN
MR.   PENCE.
I THINK HE DID MAKE A MISTAKE
WHEN HE DIDN’T GO TO THE
SOUTH KOREAN PRESIDENT’S DINNER.
YOU SHOULD GO.
SHOW UP.
IF YOU WANT TO EXPRESS YOUR
DISCONTENT OR ANGER OR YOU WANT
TO SPEAK TO SOMEBODY, DO IT.
THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
IT.
THE LARGER BEEN GOING ON IS A
DIPLOMATIC ONE IN WHICH THE
NORTH KOREANS ARE TRYING TO
DIVIDE THE UNITED STATES AND
SOUTH KOREA AND CHINA AND JAPAN
AND EVERYBODY ELSE.
I THINK WE HAVE TO BE CLEAR.
WE UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
UNIFICATION TO THE NORTH AND
SOUTH, BUT WE ARE NOT PLAYING
YOUR GAME.
>> Greg: DO YOU THINK THIS
HELPED, THE NARRATIVE HELPED HIM
AT HOME?
WE KNEW THIS WAS GOING TO BE
USED FOR PROPAGANDA PURPOSES.
IT WAS.
>> Dana: CERTAINLY HELPED HIM
AT HOME.
HE WOULDN’T HAVE DONE IT.
DOES IT HELP THEM IN SOUTH KOREA
OR DOES IT HELP PRESIDENT MOON
AND SOUTH KOREA?
THAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
I THINK THIS AMERICANS DID THE
AMERICANS -- SOUTH KOREANS DID
THE AMERICANS A DISSERVICE.
THE STAFF SHOULD HAVE THOUGHT,
IT WOULD’VE BEEN BETTER FOR MOON
AND KIM JONG UN COME IF THEY
WANT TO TALK ABOUT UNIFICATION,
TO HAVE IT REVERSED SO THE
PENCES OR ON THAT SIDE AND THE
SISTER WAS BEHIND PRESIDENT MOON
RATHER THAN BEHIND
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE.
>> Greg: WE HAVEN’T BEEN
TALKING ABOUT MUCH ELSE IN THE
OLYMPICS.
>> Dana: GOLD MEDAL.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE SAYING SHE
STOLE THE SHOW BECAUSE THEY ARE
SAYING SHE STOLE THE SHOW.
THERE IS GROUNDSWELL IN THE
WORLD FAWNING OVER THIS WOMAN.
>> Dana: PROBABLY EUROPEAN
MEDIA TOO.
THEY ARE SO MYSTERIOUS.
WE’VE NEVER SEEN HER.
THEY’VE NEVER BEEN TO
SOUTH KOREA.
TO THAT EXTENT, IT IS NEWS.
NO ONE IN THAT FAMILY HAS BEEN
TO THE SOUTH.
>> Kimberly: I DIDN’T GET THE
SWAGGER AND CHARM OR WHATEVER.
SHE WAS SORT OF JUST STANDING
THERE LIKE A STATUE.
EXAGGERATED.
I HAVE TO SAY I LIKED THE
CHEERING SECTION.
DOES THAT MAKE ME BAD?
>> Jesse: YOU CAN’T SAY THAT.
IT’S PROPAGANDA.
>> Greg: I LIKE IT WHEN PEOPLE
ALL DRESSED THE SAME.
>> Kimberly: WOW.
>> Jesse: I’M GOING TO WEAR A
V-NECK SWEATER AND A TIE.